if I showed you this picture and told  you I couldn't draw you probably  wouldn't believe me well it's true even  as an architect I genuinely do not know  how to draw very well however with more  folio trace it has elevated my game to  the next level the Simplicity of the app  really combines Tech and arts together  not only am I able to trace over images  if I want to replicate something I'm  also able to add my own Flair and steal  other peoples at the same time so by  simply throwing a stencil over the top  of my drawing I can get some amazing  architectural People Trees Landscaping  all in a matter of seconds whereas  normally I'd have to figure out how to  draw some clumpy lumpy looking thing  that looks somewhat like a tree nowadays  all I'd have to do is pick up more folio  trace and I'm only somewhat questioned  about my artistic ability  laughs